hey guys welcome to another tutorial
from simply learn this video focuses on
teaching how to use selenium IDE for
creating automation scripts what is this
video cover 1 a brief about selenium and
where the ID actually fits it very
recently a new version of IDE has been
launched so we will look at what it has
to offer how does the record and replay
tool work and then let's understand the
components of this IDE interface we will
work with few commonly used selenium
commands and then since we are near
using the new ID let's look at some of
the key features of the selenium IDE and
like every tool has its own limitations
we will also look at what are the
limitations of selenium IDE so what is
selenium so selenium is an automated
testing tool used to test web
applications across various process in
my previous video where we have covered
the complete basics of selenium
webdriver I have explained each and
every components of the selenium suite
so selenium ID is one of the components
in the selenium suite and other
components of the Sweta selenium RC
webdriver and selenium Creek so in this
video we will be looking in detail about
how the selenium IDE works so what is
selenium IDE selenium IDE was developed
way back in 2006 it was created to
facilitate a simple record and replay of
the test automation so record and replay
tools were pretty much invoked during
this time and the main advantage of
using such told was an automation
engineer was not really required to know
any knowledge of programming he could
just use this record replay tool and
create the automation and this ID was
available as a Firefox extension so for
want to use it you need to just go ahead
and install the extension on Firefox and
then use its recording and record the
steps of your test execution it is a
very simple interface which helps in
building the automation scripts and how
this works
you just need to start the recording on
ID perform your test steps on the
browser and these steps gets recorded in
the script and then what you could do is
you could export this script into say a
web driver or a j-unit ruby or any java
scripts and then you can use it now
however the record and replay tool is
not a very powerful automation tool and
hence this IDE is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
focus now since selenium-webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ID more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as I said IDE is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick tests for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium ID back in 2017 selenium IDE
development was completely stopped the
last supported Firefox version where
this ID was available as a plug-in was
Firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was removed
or it was completely broken however
recently applied tools help
reven much of the selenium ID code they
basically rewrote the whole IDE code and
then now they have released a new
version under the Apache - righto
license and it is completely managed by
the selenium community now let's look at
some of the features of this now
traditionally the selenium IDE was only
a Firefox plugin however the new IDE
supports both the browsers the chrome
and the Firefox and thus making it cross
plausible so before even we start
looking at the other features of the
selenium IDE I would like to show you
how do we install this Firefox plug-in
or the Chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome bars browser
what I'll simply do is I'll search for
selenium IDE for Chrome so then let's go
to this chrome google.com/analytics so
go ahead click on add to Chrome so this
will add this extension to your Chrome
browser so now it says selenium ID has
been added to the crew so how do you
make out if it is added so you can see
this particular icon here which says
selenium IDE so this is the way you can
go ahead and install it on the Chrome
now all the Firefox I have already
installed it since we want to use the
Firefox as a browser for all the demos
in this video so here again you can see
the selenium IDE so if I click on this
IDE it is going to open a window for me
and the first window when it opens it
says either open a new project or open
an existing project or simply you can
start a
a new test case in which case it creates
a default project for you first so what
I will do is I will say open an existing
project and I've already got the project
created so let me go to my folder we
have this project so how this project
created and I opened it I also have a
simple test case return now what this
test case does is let me show you here
it simply goes to google.com and then
here what I am doing is I am searching
for selenium HQ documentation and then I
click on this site which says selenium
HQ dot orc and Docs so which should take
us to this particular website where the
documentation is available so this is a
simple script which I have tried to
write it in this ID so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium IDE the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality
what are locators so these are nothing
but the techniques used for locating
your web elements on your website now
for example in our example here now
there type here the type which says name
equal to Q so name equal to Q is a
locator now this is a locator of what
initially if you saw I went to
google.com and this is the search button
which I used right so search text and
then I said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is named equal to Q now what happens in
ID is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
where in it also records it's multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
CSS locator it has an expert locator now
how does it help you say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what ID does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of this
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not at the West so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator that is high
possibility that test case might break
or become pretty brittle as in when the
web
elements change their attributes so this
is what the locating techniques are and
that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the functionality
in the new ID now what's the next one
parallel execution is possible with this
new ID so the first ID the traditional
one for the parallel execution was not
possible however this is a new feature
which has been added so we will be
looking in detail how to work with this
parallel execution later in this video
next is you can add control statements
in your scripts now what are this
control statements like if else while
loops for each loops and even the switch
case the earlier ID also had this
provision but you had to install a
plug-in to enable the use of this
control statement and now this new ID it
is available out of box automatically
waits for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your scripts should
not run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are were to start
feeling so it is necessary to have
enough load times on the operations of
your web elements and also enough flow
types on your page now this load time
ensures that all the elements of your
web pages and the page itself is loaded
completely before even a single line of
script is run this new IDE takes care of
providing that enough wait time and also
you have a global set speed option which
you can use to control your execution of
your scripts so that is something which
I will show you now so if I go back to
this so can you see this clock I can
here so it says test execution speed so
what you can do is right now it is set
to the fastest so I can actually control
that execution speed here so right now
I've just kept it a little slower so
let's see how our test scripts run so
you will be able to see a remarkable
difference when I slow down the complete
speed of this so now do you see how slow
it is initially when I ran it you are
unable to see what I entered in the
search field of the Google rate so now
it's clearly taking time on each of the
steps which we have mentioned it so now
it is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple JavaScript from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that
so let's take the same example here now
after clicking this okay so this is our
ID so what I will do is I'll first
execute this test case and then in the
end where I will show you how do we add
a simple JavaScript and do some
functions so let me get the speed back
to a little normal because we do not
want to waste too much time so I just
play the script once so now we are in
the selenium documentation now if you
look at this pace this is a pretty long
one so now I'm going to write a simple
java script wherein i scroll down
towards the end of this page that's all
i'm going to do now for me to do that
what i can do is in my scripts itself I
can just add another line here okay here
I will say add a new command here I'll
say execute script which is my command
and what is the script which I want to
execute it's a Java Script which I am
going to write here I'll say window dot
scroll by and I'm just going to mention
some coordinates here start from zero
and I'll say one five zero zero okay
this is all my codis and now I'll simply
run this test again let's see what
happens so it's going to the
documentation now it's clicked on the
link okay let's move to do you see this
initially it was right here on the top
of the page and once the JavaScript was
executed it brought me somewhere to the
middle of this page if that is how you
can insert a snippets of JavaScript and
it has to be in context with your
currently selected window and that's how
you run it all right let's go back to
our PPT okay what's the next feature so
every IDE has a debugger which allows
step execution adding of breakpoints now
apart from just having a breakpoints or
adding the step execution there is
another feature which it provides called
I will show you that which is called as
pause on exception so let's close this
window and let's just keep this ID
window open here so can you see your
pause button it says pause on exception
so what it does is if you enable this
button okay and when you are running the
script so if at all there happens to be
an exception in your script it stops the
execution at that particular exception
thing and we will see this in detail
when we look at complete debugger for
the ID can be integrated in CI since you
can execute scripts from command line
we also talked about the parallel
execution and you can also export the
scripts to any of the programming
language since you can do that these
scripts can be run from command line and
hence they can also be integrated with
your maven project and through Jenkins
you can run it and that's how you
achieve your CI working principle of
selenium ID selenium ID works on a very
very simple principle one is the
recording it records user interactions
with the browser and which forms
basically your ID script and using this
ID script which is a recorded script you
execute the script and very fair monitor
for its stability and success it and
thirdly what you can do is you can
simply save your recorded script for
your future runs or regression testing
and these scripts can be saved either in
the form of an ID project itself or you
can also export these test scripts into
the form of JavaScript or your Ruby
scripts or even the webdriver scripts
now let's look at the components of this
IDE interface itself the first one is
the menu bar so let's go back to our ID
window so here in the menu bar what you
can see is there's a project name so
either you can edit the project name
here or you can simply create a new
project open an existing project and
save the current project okay so these
are all the options available and since
we have already created a project here I
will not be showing how to create a new
project so that we can do it little
later now next one is the toolbar so
this is the toolbar what we have here
for the ID now there are multiple
components in the toolbar so let's see
one by one so it says run all tests now
if you have multiple test cases written
okay so this is an option where all the
tests can be run one after the other
this is to run your current tests which
the focus is on so currently our focus
is on search tests so if I click on this
button it is going to execute the search
test for me IDE has this debugger option
where you can do a step execution like
you can do step by step execution using
this option we'll see how to do that for
example let's say we start from here ok
and I click on this so what it does is
basically it has just executed the first
step for me so let's keep the
side-by-side so that we can observe the
complete execution now if I go and press
on this again step over current command
so that is the next
and it is going to execute now it says
type into this alright so now you can
see this is a lynnium HQ documentation
ok then again I say step send keys which
it basically it said enter and then it
is going to click on that documentation
which it did and now we have a script
written which Scrolls down on this
particular page so let's execute that
and that is what occurs so this is how
the step execution happens so let's
close this window and let's come back to
ID window then we have buttons here
where you can see record or you can stop
recording ok then you can pause the
execution and then there are other
options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
breakpoints any various so for example
if I want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what I have to just do is
I have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those breakpoints so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at the spa
and let's enable them for now and what
we will do is we will just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on the surround
button or you can stop the execution ok
so for now what we'll do is we'll just
stop the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your URL from where
you want to start your recording and as
and when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which are working on
next then we have a test script editor
box which is this so let me just
minimize this little bit ok this is
nothing but your test script editor box
and this is where all your script
all your interactions are recorded now
there are four attributes in this okay
can you see you come on now command is
nothing but the actual operation or the
action performed on your web element so
there are multiple actions you can
perform like in this case we have
something called as open we have got
type we have got send keys and we have
got clicks so these are all the selenium
commands which are available and then we
have something called as target now this
target is nothing but the web element on
which you want to perform the action and
now this target as I said earlier also
it is identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
those like we looked at the name here
now similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is going being used as the CSS
identifier you can also have XPath here
which is a relative XPath so these are
all the locating techniques and this is
where it which is applied on the target
value so value is an optional field so
you can send any value to your web
element for example in this case where
we are sending the value which is our
text which is selenium HQ dot
documentation so this is the value which
I want to send it to as a search text to
make google.com and then comment or the
description so here you can mention any
description about that particular line
which you have recorded for example I
can say here sending search text to the
Google search input box and this gets
recorded here against your raw
instruction now let's look at the test
case pin now test case pin that is here
so if you look here now it contains all
the test cases which you have recorded
now there are multiple things here one
is your tests say I can always go ahead
and create another to say our test case
- okay I can add a few more test case
here test case 3 so all these test cases
are here now
I can also have a test suite now there's
already test suite which I've created
which is called the Google suite and now
if I want to add test cases under this
what I can do is I can just say address
and now I can add any of the stress
which I just created under this test
suite so say I've selected the first
three and I've added it so we have test
suite we have tests here and then
execute it so it
securing is basically it shows that
particular test case which is currently
in the execution mode so whichever test
case we run you will see all the test
cases listed here which have been
executed at that point of time that is
your test case page and then we have
test log and reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running log
so as and when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every tested as in when it runs it is
going to log here whether it has passed
whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it's a running
log also there is something called as
reference time now for example just go
ahead and let's select one of this
command which you have written here
which is send keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locate or clicks on the
target segment it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script knob for say
Amazon dot it so let's go back to our ID
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so like I'll
click on the create new project are you
sure you would like to without saving it
yes proceed further and let's give the
name as Amazon Project now in this new
project what I will do is I will say
I'll add a test and my test name is
search iPhone so basically what is the
use case which I am going to automate us
I will launch Amazon dot and I will
search for iPhones and once I get the
iPhones let's verify the title of that
particular page now just the simple
steps we'll go ahead and do that so for
that first what I need to do is I need
to enter the URL now this URL needs to
be a fully formed urine so for that what
I will do I'll first launch Amazon dot
on any browser I'll just copy this URL
and I can close this browser window and
in this URL address space I would say I
miss or Tata and I'll say enter and now
I would click on this recording button
which say start recording so once I do
this what it does is it launches the
webpage with Amazon dot it and from
there I can start recording my screen so
let's do that
I say record it so let me just keep this
window side by side so that you can see
what is happening on the ID window here
now here what I will do is I'll click on
the search
say iPhone and I will click on the
search button and here I will also click
on this best seller once I'm in this
window I'll say right click now when
your selenium ID is in the recording
mode you will get this option here which
says selenium idea and there are a lot
of options here which you can select now
for this particular moment what I want
to do is I want to assert the title so I
just put an assertion point here for
assert idea and then I will close my
browser and now let's see what are all
the commands which it has recorded let's
go one by one okay so it is done it is
opening the Amazon dot in it is setting
the window size fine it clicked on the
two search window button and then iPhone
is what we are searching and then it
said submitted it's basically clicking
on that button and then we said we also
want to open the bestseller link and
here is our assert title all right so
it's a very simple test so let's go
ahead and execute this now since I also
have a close command here this script is
going to execute so fast that you will
not be able to make out all the steps
what we have written so for that what I
will do I will comment on this line now
how do you comment out any command here
just select the command and can you see
your enable and disable comments just
click on it so now your command is
disabled also what I will do is I will
reduce the execution speed so that you
should be able to see exactly what is
happening so let's go ahead and execute
this test first so I'll say run current
test ok I have not stopped the recording
so that is the first thing after closing
the window I also need to click on the
stop recording now your script is ready
to be executed so let's go on run the
current script again I will just bring
the side-by-side so that you can see
each of these commands being executed
here ok the search for the iPhone it's
clicked on the bestsellers and it has
done the title assertion now if you look
at the log here as I said every step as
in when it was executed it has been
logged here can you see her and it puts
an OK and it color coded in green which
says that this particular command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did by simply
recording all the steps from the browser
now one more thing what we will do is
say I want to continue recording here
right are not completed my test case so
what you can still do here
you can come towards the end of the
script and press on record button again
and then you can continue recording from
here now say for example after the
bestsellers what we have got say I want
to click on say hot releases what new
releases so I do that okay it says it
has recorded the click and then I want
to stop the recording just the another
step is what I wanted to add now it has
stopped the recording so can you see
this new line which has got at it so
that means you really need not restart
recording all the steps again if you
want to add something in the middle of
your screen you can always go towards
the end of the script or anywhere in
between and you can add more commands
there or you can record anywhere in
between the script and that is our Vista
so let's go ahead and again execute this
then I will show you another feature of
this it's done the title assertion now
and it is also clicked on hot new
releases that now let's say for example
I need to add another command here now
instead of going ahead and using this
recording what I will do is I'll
manually add certain command here say
for example let's go to this Amazon
website and say you want to click on
this car so let me add a command
manually here so what does my command my
command is click and then what is that I
want to click I need to identify that
web element for that I can use this here
it says select the target in the page so
I click on that and I simply select this
target which is my cut and that is all I
need to do so my command is written
there so I'll just simply go ahead and
execute this again let's see what
happens so let me close this window here
ok let's run this test cases bring this
window to the side so now you can see
one by one the instructions being
executed
ok the iPhone has been searched the
bestseller has been clicked assert title
so it says your shopping cart has
emptied so that means it is successfully
able to click on the cart so now with
using ID there are multiples think you
can do you can simply record your script
while you are running your test case you
can add a command all by yourself you
can stop recording anywhere and again
restart from the same point now we have
our complete test script ready now let's
go ahead and save this so how do you
save this simply go here and save your
complete project so on the project from
the ID are saved as dot side fight so
let's name
Amazon project and I will save it so if
I show you in my finder how it looks
like this is a project we created so it
always stores with the file extension
dot s ID write that with selenium ID now
also I said you can export test cases
into multiple format so such iPhone is
my test case so what I can do is I can
just say right-click and as I can say
export now right now you can see only
three options
it says Java j-unit Java scripts and
Python however the older ide had
multiple options of export which had
even the webdriver scripts and also the
Java scripts this is still in works and
they would be adding more support for
other programming languages here so but
for now the only options what is
available to us is Java j-unit
JavaScript and the Python so let's go
ahead and export this into Java j-unit
so it is going to simply save it as dot
Java file let me go here in the IDE test
I will save this file so if you go back
to my finder you can find our search
iPhone test or Java they can open their
Java file they can you can see here it's
a simple j-unit test it has exported
into so if you have an eclipse ide you
can use this test and executed from your
eclipse ide selenium commands selenium
commands can be broadly classified into
three action commands accessors and
assertions what are action commands
action commands are the commands which
interact directly with the web elements
on your application so let's look at
what these commands are so if we go back
to our previous example where we had
written a test script for amazon dot
so if you look at all these things like
open set window size click type so these
are all nothing but called as action
commands and if you go here you can see
let me do one thing so let me just come
to a blank line and now let's look at
the list of commands so you have a whole
list of commands here listed in the
alphabetical order like add selection
there are multiple assert commands which
is made available to you and then there
are set of commands very sick like or
click at a particular location closing
the browser using a debugger command
double click drag and drop echo I just
explained how to use an echo command so
this is a command which is not or used
on your web element but something which
you want to say display on your console
and then
if L statements which are used as
commands here then you have something
called as execute script for you to
execute any sa JavaScript or any
different script which you want to
execute from your descriptio and then
you have few Mouse commands here open
which is what we use for opening our new
Arden pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use these commands in your
scripts so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what I
will do is towards the end of the script
I'll just add this command I'll say echo
and say I want to just display a message
saying that this is the end of the
script execution that is all I want to
do now I'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the lock so now if you observe here
so go to this last statement what we
have so it says after clicking on the
card it's an echo this is the end of the
script so this is what we displayed and
using the command echo okay so this is
how you can use the echo comic another
feature here what you can do here is now
say for example I just added a simple
echo statement here now for me to
execute that what I did was I executed
the complete script you really need not
do that always instead of that what I
can do is I can just come to this
particular line I can just say right
click and I can say play from here so
what it does is from this point it is
going to play the script for me and not
right from the beginning of the script
so I'll show you how now with this
command if you look here see it started
running the script here it says running
search iPhone and then it executed only
one command which says echo this is the
end of the script so this is also
possible to do with the ID accessors
accesses for the selenium commands that
examine the state of an application and
store the results in a variable so these
are those commands which allows the user
to store say certain values into your
user defined variables and these stored
values can be later on used either to
create assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
I have few store commands here which
I'll be demo so first one is a store
using a store command you can store any
kind of user-defined messages in a
variable and then after that you can
either use it for displaying it on your
console or you can do some assertions
with that similarly store title so you
can to store the title of any of the
webpage under test then store text so
store text is basically used to capture
the text attribute of any web element on
your webpage and store it in a variable
use it as an assertion point store value
so store value again is used to store
the value attribute of any web element
like so you have a lot of web elements
on the web page and say one of the
attributes is what you want to do an
assertion on so what you can do you can
use the store value command here get the
value attribute of your web element and
store it in a variable so let's all see
all these commands in action so let's go
back to the same example so we have this
Amazon test script example so what I'll
do is say instead of using Amazon let's
do one thing so let's create another
test case itself so I'll go here
I'll say add new test and I will name
this test as access a test and we will
use the same Amazon site here I'll say
click on start recording keep this
window side-by-side so first we will
look at store title so simply what I
need to do is go to this Amazon site
which you have learnt right click on
this go to the selenium ID and you have
multiple options here so go ahead and
select store title so once I click on
that it is going to ask me the variable
name where I want to store the title of
this page so let's create a variable
here and save a title and I'll say ok
done now come back to your ID all right
so I will stop the execution here now I
have the store title command I created a
variable called Val title and I'm
storing the actual title into this
variable so let's also display this on
our console so I'll add the command here
echo and in target how do I use the
variable now this is the way to use it I
will say dollar and in Flour braces I
will give the variable name which I have
defined earlier it is bad i TLD title
okay so this is all my script is where
I'm storing the title of the webpage and
I'm displaying it in my console or the
lock so now there are some extra
commands which gets added
no because we are doing the recording on
that so whatever the mouse movements
happen it is going to record we do not
need this so I will go ahead and delete
this particular command so let's close
this window and execute this test first
so the script is executed successfully
but let's go and see whether did we get
the title displayed on the console yes
so it it did open the Amazon site it has
set the window size it captured the
title here in this line and then after
assigning you to the variable we said
echo and that variable name and it is
displayed as the title of the page so
now similarly let's go ahead and let's
see how do we use the store text command
now for store text I need an use case
here say for example whatever the Scott
let's say we want to display the text of
this particular element now there are
text of this element is cut so now
instead of again going and re-recording
on the steps I will simply manually add
this command so now after displaying the
title okay so let's go ahead here and I
will say store text and in store text I
need to pick the text from this web
element cut so what I will do is I'll
use the Stargate select target and I
will select this particular element
which is cut after this I need to create
a variable where it can be stored cell
say where card text now similarly I will
also display it using echo comma echo
dollar in the flower braces and save
text so let's execute this and then
let's look at the other command so I'll
just say I'll close this window again
run this test so now look at this log
lines so our last statements was storing
the title and displaying the title after
that we added store text okay so here is
the command and said it is executed
successfully it was able to retrieve the
text from the element cart and the text
retrieved was scarred and which is what
got displayed with the echo statement on
our console so now let's move to next
store command which is store value now
as I said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website
I have the search button so I will right
click on this and I say inspect element
now look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit' and
also it has this value attribute which
is gioco and this is exactly what i want
to retrieve and print so we will be
using the search button now similarly
same thing what I will do here I'll go
ahead add a command here as a store
value same way I will select the target
as a select target from page I will
click on the search button for it so
here it has taken the target here in the
value I will mention the variable name
where I want to store the value so it's
a ver button and value and similarly I
will say echo and I will print the value
of this variable which is dollar
Val BTN value let's go ahead and execute
this I'd say run current test so it has
taken the title it has printed the value
on the line seven so it's a store value
on this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable VAD BTN value
so that command was successful and the
value actually which was got stored and
which we retrieved using echo statement
was gioco and that's exactly what we had
here if you want to check again go here
to inspect element the one which is
highlighted so as we said the value is
go and that's exactly got printed on
above console now apart from this I also
said there is a simple command which is
just stored so let's use that also now
after all this here I will say store and
say we want to just store or user
message I would say a target as all
store commands demoed and this message I
will capture it in a variable save their
strength since his sister text and then
like I did it in the other string and
I'll say echo and the variable name so
now if we close this and one way to do
it us execute the complete test so which
will execute all our store commands and
also the last line is this the line
number nine in the log which says the
store command which we use to store the
text all store commands demoed and that
is also displayed using the egg so all
the store common
we have demoed successfully let's close
this window and go back to our
presentation so this is all about the
access of come on now what do we have
after accessor so we have something
called as assertions now what is an
assert so assertion is nothing but it
verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected results
now assertions are of three different
types one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert thus when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails the test stops immediately after
this statement so if you are asserting
say a title of a page and if you find
that the title of page is not as
expected as soon as it finds that
failure your rest of the test case test
is not going to run and it's going to
immediately stop the test and also it is
going to flag the test cases fail what
is verify verify something where the
selenium ID it logs that particular
assertion as fail however it would
continue with the rest of the steps in
the test case and then at the end of it
the your overall test case is flagged as
fail that is what verified us so verify
is called a soft assertion
whereas assert here is called as hard
assertion why it is called harder
session because as soon as an assert
statement fits the complete test
execution stops at that statement
whereas in soft as Earth what happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the steps and
continue it completes its execution and
then flags the test cases failure and
Venice is usually used in cases like as
the same example say if you are
asserting a title you really do not want
the test case execution to stop even if
there is a failure
why because none of your steps are going
to be dependent on this assertion point
and this is where you will require a
softer self wait for wait for something
which wears for a certain condition to
be true after that it proceeds to your
further steps so if the condition goes
Falls here for whatever say if we are
waiting for an element to appear on the
webpage and if that element does not
appear the test fails however it carries
forward and completes the test by
executing the rest of the steps and then
flags the complete test case as a
failure
which will be something similar to a
softer search so
see all these things in action let's go
back to our ID we will create another
test case here so I will say a third
test now for this what's the example we
can take so first for us our title let's
do those assert title on Amazon itself
and let's change the same test case to
verify and see how this desk is behave
now for this I will launch the recorder
with the same amazon.com is launched now
simply I will go to this website and
I'll say right click selenium ID and
I'll say assert title then I will stop
the recording now here I will remove
this command which has got added which I
don't need so this is my asserted now we
have already seen our third title
passing in couple of four other examples
now I want to show you a failure on us
so for that what I will do I will modify
this actual type so here in the last
line I'll just remove this Amazon Datuk
so now ideally this test case is going
to fail for us because that ITIL which
it is expecting and what it is comparing
against are not the same
first let's execute this well I also
need to show some statements after this
so what I will do is let's add a few
more statements here let me start the
recording here again say after asserting
the title we want to go and click on
this bestseller and then I will close
this now let's execute this stop the
recording and execute this test now do
you see this assert title is in red that
means it has failed the validation here
so now you see here in the lock it says
open the side done set window sighs done
when it comes to assert title it says
actual value was something different and
it did not match with what you are
trying to look for a certain ended with
monitor now after this assert please
observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as Hardison now let's go
ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what I will do in
the command itself instead of assert I
will say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
I say run test running assert test
Amazon Rotten was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified it however
you see this fourth line being executed
click on link test best-seller and click
on close now since I it was a very fast
execution and I closed the browser
probably was you were not able to see
the bestsellers click here that is fine
but in the log we can see here that the
steps four and five got executed even
after the title verify title steps field
and if you compare it with the previous
example where a sir title failed the two
lines after that the line for where we
are clicking on the bestseller and
closing the browser are not getting
executed so this is the main difference
between the verify title and a subtitle
so now let's look at wait for how do we
use wait for now for wait for I want to
look at some kind of website where it
would load an element dynamically after
I buy it so for that I have a website
here let's let's create a new test again
let's go to the test Spain I will say
assertion test and now let's put a
browser we open a new window and there
is the demo site which I want to use so
let me search for that and then I will
use that URL so I'll say Internet I'm
going to use the dynamic loading we have
yes dynamic loading page now see if you
look at this website when I press on the
start button right after that file this
hello what text is going to appear on
this web page so in our use case what we
will do we will launch this website we
will click on the start button and then
we will put an assert on this text using
wait for let's do that so let's go here
let me copy this this is the one may say
ctrl C and in my new test I'll say ctrl
V and then and say start ricotta is
going to launch this
let's close the previous Windows now in
this I'm just going to click on start so
that is going to get recorded done and
now while the recording is still on I
will add a command here for wait for so
I'll say wait for element visible that
is exactly what we are saying right so
wait for is used until for a condition
and until that condition is true so I am
saying here please wait for this
particular element which I'm going to
give it in target until it is visible
now the target is I'm just going to
select the target from this webpage
itself so
select target and I'm going to select
this particular text come back here to
your ID so wait for the element to be
visible what is the element to be
visible is this hello world hello white
text and then you need to give a value
here
now what does this value since we are
using wait for we need to mention it
time on so we have to tell basically to
ID that okay wait for say one second two
seconds or three seconds whatever it is
required and that timeout value is needs
to be mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what I will say is I'll
say so let's fail this test case first
so I'll use a little lesser time work so
I'll say 3000 so that is 3,000
milliseconds which is three seconds that
is and then we can say so what we'll do
here is we'll add an assert so I will
say assert text now what is the assert
text I am going to do I need to look for
the same element so I'll simply say
select target this one and what is that
I'm going to assert with I'm going to
assert with the same text so I just copy
this text and I'll put it in the value
then another way of doing that which we
have done it previously so I can just go
here do a right click go to selenium ID
and I can say asar text which is
basically going to give me the same
command so let me just go ahead and
remove one of them either of them you
can crémeux okay so let's stop the
recording i will not close this browser
because i want you to see how the
dynamically loaded element behaves and
will go ahead and execute this so I'll
say stop recording let's say execute
this test now it's here all right so
it's waiting okay it is fade now see
this so it says wait for element visible
after that the value we have mentioned
is 3000 that is wait for three seconds
which was not enough because and it
failed with saying that unable to locate
the element within the timer period now
let's go ahead and change it to a
passing value so I will say 10,000 here
with just 10 seconds so let's close this
and let's again execute this bring this
to the side so that we can see okay
it is waiting on that wait for element
now look at the problem here what we
have done is we have closed the website
and after that we have added the assert
text so this is a mistake what we have
done and hence daughters found that
element here for wait for what did you
do it went ahead close the window and
after that
it's definitely not going to find our
sir Tech right so that's the mistake
what we have done so let's go ahead and
debug this so what we will do after this
wait for element we want this assert to
be put after that we don't need this
click content because this was an
additional step which got added delete
it and then chose okay fine so now let's
go ahead and drill on this set on
current test I'll move this to a side
okay it's waiting all right done so now
it is able to do an ice or text on this
alright so this is how you use the wait
for key features of selenium ID let's
look at the first feature reusability of
test scripts so many of the test scripts
have test steps that involves signing
into an application or creating a NACA
like for example a login screen is a
very key example in this case where
whenever you are testing your
application first you need to log in and
then perform any other test so now it's
going to be a redundant or a waste of
time to recreate the login steps again
and again for each and every test case
so we do not want to definitely do that
so as we know since a record and replay
tool does not have enough capability of
writing a common test cases or a common
functions and calling those common
functions like our regular selenium
webdriver has however what ID is done is
it has given us a provision to run one
script from another script so what
basically what we do here is especially
for a login we write one test case which
is going to login to your application
and call this test case in the other
test cases so let's layer take a look at
how this works so for that lets go to
our ID so in this ID we'll do one thing
we let's go ahead and create a new
project so let's say login project in
this project I will create a new test
case we'll just call it as login test
let's say add now in this login test I
need to give a URL now for this purpose
I will be using again a demo site so
first let me launch a demo site here
file new window and see the demo site go
dot uk'
ok this is a simple demo site which has
a login functionality right so here I
will go to the login screen now this
also allows me to add few users and
using the same users
go ahead and do the loggin now coming
back to our login page so this is the
URL which I need to launch which is
going to give us username and password
we will use to login into this
application so give this URL here and
say start recording move this window
here for recording and this here now
what is the first step we want to record
we want to come here click on the
username and I'll say user one okay and
I'll say password PWD one and I will
click on test login and then what we
will do is we will assert this text so
here I'll say right click selenium ID
assert text that's it and then I will
close the browser yes this is all my
test is now come back to your ID let's
see if there are any unnecessary
commands which it has taken ok click
type all done and now for the time being
I'm going to comment out this closed
comment because I want the browser to be
still open so that we can see the actual
test execution properly till the end of
the script this is the login test case
now simply if I run this let's execute
this let me execute this in show stop
the recording and execute this test case
so it typed user 1 it typed PWD which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me fail
docking so this is past fantastic
however this is with one value I have
used it but this is a function which I
want to use it every time and also the
probable use case I might have is that I
might need to login with a different
user ID and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page I
would want to test with multiple user ID
and password
like valid credentials and invalid
credentials so for that purpose what we
will do is we will parameterize this
name that is user ID and the password
and how do I parameterize it simply go
here instead of giving a hard-coded
value here what you can do is just says
use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
I'll say user names this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard-coded value I'll
say dollar and I will say password now I
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login tour test what I will do now
is I will create my
chill test case so I'll say here I'll
say invalid credential as my test case
and they'll say add now here is where I
will assign values for my variable now
which are those variables I need to use
username and password so I need to
assign some value here and then call
this function login test so let's do
that in this video
previously we also saw how do we use
user variables and how do we assign
value by using the store command so I'm
going to say store and then my target is
going to be the actual value so user 1
and where is that I'm going to pass this
to my variable username let's just check
once if the variable name is username
yes all right done now I have done the
user name now I need to pass the
password so I again L say store the
actual password which is PWD 1 in my
case and what is the variable I need to
use here I have to use password because
that's the variable which we have used
in login test yes and then after that I
need to use a command which is called as
run now what this run command does is
said run and whatever target you give
which is basically or another test case
it is going to run the test case now in
our case our testers login test this is
all our test case is going to be ok so
what is that we did we do in this test
case we created a variable username and
password and assign the actual username
and password and then we are just
calling this login test and in this
login test this username and password
will get passed which will be user 1 and
PWD 1 and then it will execute this test
with the or with the value which we have
passed to this variable names so now
which test case we need to run the
invalid credentials so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test here running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user 1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the user name and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how use it so
now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test I'll say valid credentials
and let's say add now same thing I will
do here I'll say command store my target
will be now I'll say user 3 value will
be username right okay
now second command will be again storing
this time it is for the password my
password is PWD 3 and the variable name
is password and same thing I'll just
called run and my login test that's now
similarly let's run this test and see
what happens now this test is going to
fail why let me close this window I
don't need this why did this test case
fail because my assertion point let's go
to the test so should my assertion point
in login test is look for failed logon
however we created a test case for valid
credentials right because our valid
credentials who said that the login was
successful we did not match with what we
were asserting which is fine right so we
just wanted to see whether we can write
a test case with valid credentials and
invalid credentials and this is how you
do that by passing the variables through
your test case to your actual test case
the next feature is the debugger in the
ID like every other ID offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium ID so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium IDE
offices so one is called as a step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques work what
I will do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our ID
and I will create a new test case so a
new test case let's use a facebook login
this time so I'll say FB login test or
will just say FB test so now for this FB
test I would go ahead and use the
Facebook login page so I'll just copy
this URL paste it here and then I will
minimize this other Firefox window and I
will launch the recorder now so I'll
click on start recording now let's keep
this side-by-side and what is that we
are going to do here is let's do a
simple login functionality so I'll just
use some email id here I'll say my user
at gmail.com this is just a dummy user
ID and password I'll use and I'll say
password has password 1 then I'll click
on login but let's stop the recording
here let's read the script once whether
it has got everything whatever we need
ok it does launched Facebook it clicked
on email ID there's a double clicks here
because I happen to click twice on the
email ID field so what I'll do I'll
remove one we don't need it and then I'm
typing the keys which is my user dot
Gmail and then I'm clicking on the
password field typing the password and
clicking on the login button and then
once I do that ok so I'm going to get
this pages the password you've entered
is incorrect so let it be so we will use
the script until here and check out some
of the login options ok so we have
completed writing of the script let me
go ahead and close this window now first
thing what we will do is we'll just
simply execute the script so we have to
just say run current test so it's going
to login your Facebook it will enter my
user a Gmail it'll enter the password it
will login and that's about it
so now your script is executed now let's
go into the debug mode as we said there
are multiple options for debugging
what is the first option let's see the
first option we have is something called
a step execution so what the step
execution does is from your script you
can execute all the steps one after the
other so you can basically control the
execution of each step and how you do
that what you have to do is just go and
click anywhere so let's start from the
beginning let's close this window
of our previous run and there is an
option here which says step over current
command so when you click on this what
it does is it basically executes your
first line where your cursor was and it
stops immediately after that so if you
look here it has launched the Facebook
page which says open the URL Facebook
and then let's go ahead and just do the
simple step execution again I will click
on that it is going to execute this
command where it said the window size to
a certain value again I will do a step
execution now observe what happens here
it clicked on this email field you see
the cursor there now let's do the next
step again again I will do step over
current command now the current command
was it entered my user and Gmail you can
see it on the left side
now it would be more visible again I
will do a step execution it is going to
click on the password field now it is
going to enter the password and now the
last step is is going to click on the
login button and with this all our
commands are executed and this is how
you do the step execution and now where
is this useful say if you've got a very
long test case written and you want at
certain point you want to start doing
the step execution to see where your
test cases failed probably one of your
web element you enter the strong or
probably the text which are entered is
wrong so for you to debug such cases you
can use this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
breakpoints so there are breakpoints
which you can insert in your script so
let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what I will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what I do
is I simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right-click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now I've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till you a
breakpoint it will execute all the
commands before that and it stops or
pauses your execution at this point ok
let's go ahead and see how it does so
what I will do is I've added a
breakpoint at the click on password
field and I will say execute this test
do you see how it says paused in the
debugger so by adding breakpoint my test
has entered the debugging mode and where
has it stopped - at the point where I
added this breakpoint
so just go back here and see whether the
previous steps have been executed yes my
previous step was adding this my user at
gmail.com into the email field which it
is done and it has paused here and now
from here I can either run the rest of
the tests if I just click on this run
current test what it will do is it will
go ahead and execute all the steps or
even I can do a step execution from here
so say if I want to do a step execution
I will do
this let me minimize this window a
little bit so that you can see and I'm
still again doing that step execution so
it added the password and after this
I'll say just go ahead and complete the
test so it is clicked on your signing
login button and it is logged in so this
is how you can use the breakpoint so
that is about adding the breakpoint
let's see what's the next removing the
breakpoint so I showed you so if you
want to add a breakpoint you just click
here or you can do a right-click and do
toggle breakpoint if you want to remove
the breakpoint just click again on the
same place where it has added the
breakpoint or you can always do this
toggle breakpoint so this is the way of
adding and removing the brick buts
what is the third option disabled now
say for example my test cases are pretty
long well ok so I might have a multiple
breakpoints so say let's add one
breakpoint here at the email and then
before clicking on login let's add
another break but now when I execute
this it is going to stop here and then
again if I say continue execution it is
going to come and stop here so let's do
that first and then I'll show you how
the disable box so let's close this
window again execute this bring this
window here can you see this it's
positive ok and here now you should be
able to see now I'll say just run after
this breakpoint
do you see your it is paused after
entering the password it has not clicked
on the login button it's paused at the
click and now I will say again complete
the test so your click on the login
button is done and it is locked in so
it's a little bit slow yeah now you got
that login page at some point of time
while I'm debugging my test case I would
want to just disable all the breakpoints
and not remove everything for that I
have an option here which says disable
breakpoint so if this button is
highlighted here that means I have
selected disable break one so what this
does is when I execute this test it
ignores all this breakpoints for this
run it ignores this breakpoints until I
have selected this disable breakpoint
but ok so let's see this let me close
this again and I have enabled this
disable breakpoint is what I have
selected I'll just simply go ahead and
run this test case do you see that it
did not stop at this breakpoint it went
ahead and completed the execution why
because I have temporarily disabled it
once I remove the selection and run it
it is again going to stop at the
breakpoints so this is how
it works so we saw adding of requires
removing of breakpoints and disabling of
breakpoints what is the next one
enter debugger by using play to this
point option okay now another way of
doing this is so let's remove on this
breakpoint now for example like the last
time you said we want to add a
breakpoint here so now instead of doing
that what I can do also do is I can just
right click on that particular command
and I can say play to this point only so
when I select this what happens it acts
like a breakpoint and it comes and
pauses at this particular command where
I have set play till this point so let's
try to do that so let me close this
window and then for say type the
password so here okay I'll say right
click play to this point so it is going
to execute all the steps until the
password and it will stop here can you
see this paused in the debugger so it
again enter the debug mode and now it
has stopped at this point so now there
are multiple options now every time last
time what we did we did a step over and
also we said continue with the rest of
the test now what we will do will just
stop the execution so this is also an
option available say if you want to
change something yet you do not want to
continue with your execution you can
simply go ahead and stop the execution
so we saw how do we use the play to this
point option now debugger command now
all these things whatever we did now
adding the breakpoints this was done in
the ID there is also a way of adding a
debugger programmatically and how do we
do that let's see now in the same place
say after entering the password so here
I will insert a command in this command
I'll just say debugger this is all the
commands now what happens when I execute
this test case is at this point wherever
it finds this debugger command this
program enters into a debug mode and it
comes and pauses the script here let's
see this in action
so simply I'll just play the script
let's type the email id it's typed the
password okay it is going little slower
here okay and there there you go now it
is paused in debugger so this debugger
did the same job as what we did earlier
with the break pots now let's go ahead
and just stop the execution because
let's not keep logging into Facebook
with invalid username an ID okay so this
is how you can use the debugger command
so I will stop the execution here close
this window and now let's see the next
one let's close this window so we saw
the debug pause on exception okay this
is a very brilliant feature of this
I D I'll show you how it works now let's
say let me remove this command now I do
not want the debugger I'll say delete
this command let's click let it be there
now if you look at this what we are
doing is we are identifying this
elements like email password and then
clicking on the login button now say for
example say this click so let's run this
then I'll show you what it is
and I want it to come and stop here okay
so I will execute this all right so now
it has paused here so now what I will do
is the click write so this is where I am
clicking is this login button so this
login button
is identified by some identifier which
is an ID now there is a possibility that
tomorrow this particular ID might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because this script will say that
this element is not formed in such cases
if you are using pause on exception that
is here pause on exception what happens
is whenever this script finds an
exception it goes and pause aside that
and enters into a debug mode otherwise
what happens whenever you find an
exception your complete test script will
stop executing because there is an error
and your test case phase instead since
we are in a debugging mode if you choose
this option what happens is if there is
an exception it is going to come get
into the debugger mode and it is going
to pause the execution at that point and
once it pauses what you can do is you
can go and correct it and then continue
our execution so let's see that in
action so now for example a click button
so here the idea is you underscore 0
underscore a so say I try to change this
let me add one here and then if I
execute this this script should fail
form basically because it is not going
to find us so can you see is trying to
find this ID and since this particular
element with this ID does not exist this
whole test case should fail for now as I
said earlier in this video so if by any
chance if one of the element ID is not
found so if that is not found it always
falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other idea that's what
it says element found with the secondary
locator to use it by default update that
step and to use it as a primary locator
and that is where the test case passed
so let's try to see if I can make this
test case fail in any way for that let's
remove this let's try on the email ID so
what I will do is let me try to comment
this out remove the debugger and I will
add a command here I'd say insert new
command and in this I will say click and
then I will use the target as ID equal
to email now in this case I do not have
a fallback ID because I am not using ID
to recognize the element rather I added
my own command and I added my own
locator here so now let's try with this
and now install this is the right ID so
what I will do is I'll just change this
ID to something like underscore one so
that this test case fails for me now let
me close this and let's run this test
case and basically this test case should
fail so if you see here in the log it's
saying trying to find the element with
ID email underscore one so this ID has a
default time up so it will keep trying
to find the element until the time what
value is completed now there we go so it
had an implicit time out of thirty
thousand so that is thirty seconds
thirty thousand milliseconds which was
thirty seconds now after that this desk
is filled so this is the scenario we
wanted what happens here is it simply
started executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back look for this red lines where
it has failed
corrected and then rerun the whole test
now instead of that what this pause on
exception does is let me click on that
so this is what is selected now what it
does is when I execute this this is
going to come and stop here let's see
that so let me close this and run this
program again so run current test I'll
bring this to the side now see yes it's
trying to find the ID since the timeout
is almost 30 seconds we need to wait
until it pauses at this so now do you
see this now it is not exited from the
test it is just at the same step where
it is unable to find this email field
okay and it's saying okay it failed with
an implicit time out of 30 seconds but
now since I am in the debugging mode and
how did I get into the debug mode by
selecting this option pause on exception
now what I can do is I can go ahead and
change this back to the actual one and
then
from here I can just simply do this I
can say run the test now so now see what
it did
the moment I changed that and I said run
it fast and how did it pass because I
gave the right ID here and that's
exactly you can do with this debugger
control flow statements so in the legacy
ID these control flow statements were
available as plug in so one had to
install the plugin for you to use any of
this control flow statements however in
the new IDE these are available out of
box so let's see what this control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping so in
conditional branch we have a regular
if-elsif nested if-else and end and when
we talk about looping there are multiple
loops available one is the while anglo
so how does the while end loop work the
code between the while and the end is
executed until the expression is true
and then we have a do repeat SoDo repeat
where the commands after the do will get
executed first and then the condition is
checked and this is evaluated in this if
statement times n so you can specify a
number of iterations you would like a
piece of code to be executed using this
loop and then there's another loop which
is a for each loop so this provides the
ability to I trait over collection
objects let's say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let's go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what I will do is I will demonstrate a
use case for the if-else and then for
the looping I have a few the scripts
which I've already written which I will
show you and I will walk you through
them it's a simple counter which we can
use where it will be incrementing the
counter using one of these loops so we
will just see how the loops are to be
used what is the syntax to be use and
how they execute in the IDE so let's go
to our ID now let's minimize this so
this was our previous test case so
whatever you do is I will close this
project and open another project so I
have another project here which is
called as control flows so as I said I
have few scripts written for
some of the loop however for the demo
you skills we will go ahead and write a
new script it's all say add new test and
we are going to be working with a demo
site called calorie calculator so let me
name the test case itself as calorie
calculator test so let's look at what is
our use case now in this use case this
is my use case I'm saying go to this
calorie counter website okay so let's
see what that website is I have this
website open here so this is a calorie
calculator website in this website we
are saying if the gender is male then
click on the male radio button so you
have multiple fields here where you are
accepting the age of a person the gender
of a person the hide the weight and then
the activity level of the person and
when when you click on calculate this is
going to give you the number of calories
so for our purpose for our demo use case
what we will do is we will store the
gender to be selected in a variable say
for example I want a gender female to be
selected and then I'm going to write an
if condition here that if the gender is
male right so if the gender is male then
click on the male radio button here and
then I'm saying click active from the
activity drop-down so there's a
drop-down called activity here in this I
am going to go and select active as
daily exercise or intense exercise three
to four times a week this is what I'm
going to be selecting and if the gender
is female so if the value passed from
the gender is female then what is that I
want to do I want to click on this radio
button female and select very active
intense exercise from this activity
doctor a very simple use case so this is
what we are going to write in our test
script so let's minimize this fit or we
can just close this window for now we
don't need this and here so how do we
start this test case I need to enter the
URL so for me to enter the URL let me go
to that copy this URL control C minimize
this and control V dot so now I'm here I
will start my recording by clicking on
the start recording button so now this
URL is open now the first thing what I
need to do is in my test script I need
to write a open command so I'll say open
and my target is what this you are done
the next command is as per our use case
I want to store the gender to be
selected in a
variable so we will use the store
command and when we use the store
command we need to specify the target so
let's say the target is and where is
that I want to store I'll create a Vash
gender that's my variable so have stored
thus now what is the next thing I want
to do so once I have stored this first
as I need to put an if statement because
my use case is if the gender is male and
if the gender is female
now since by default the male is already
selected here so let's put an if
condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what I'm going to do so here I will say
if in the command once I say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is I want to check for
dollar that's my variable where gender I
want to check if this is equal to F and
how is that I can check I need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes I'm going
to mention F now this is what I've
stored in the variable that gender this
is what I'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line
now all the next lines whatever I'm
going to mention are the ones which will
be executed if this condition is true
now in the next line what I want is I
want to select this radio button okay so
now what I will do instead of writing
all the commands manually I will now use
our recorder to do that since I'm
already in the recording mode I just go
to the URL of the website here and I'll
go click on this female so on the right
if you see these steps are getting
recorded and then our disc is also said
that from the activity drop-down we want
to select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
I clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the ID activity here
which is our activity drop-down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here I will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male ok
what is that we want to do I want to go
and select in the activity field as
active because the male is already
selected so I'm not going to select it
again and then I will end the if loop by
end statement
so this is all my script is so let's
stop the recording here there are some
mouse move mouse up which I really do
not need so what I will do is I'll just
delete this so this is the simple
statement what I need in the ELLs where
I am saying select to select is
something a command which is used to
select a web element which is your
drop-down so you select the drop down
here and once the drop down is clicked
and then you go ahead and click on where
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily excesses or intense
this value from the drop down is what I
am selecting and same same thing what we
did in the if statement so let's remove
these also we don't know mouse move pad
and mouse up act so all these statements
we don't need so same thing if I'm
saying the if statement says if the
gender is F that is female click on the
radio button then go to the select
activity select the activity by clicking
on vary actor and then end the loop so
this is all our script Asst now let's go
ahead and execute this and see whether
it works so let's minimize this window
and I will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed a little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now I'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is opened so we are
passing the value F for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the lock so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the Select field which is your
activity drop-down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what I
will do instead of F less passed the
value and mate and let's see what
happens and then we will go ahead and
execute this program so let's close this
window again and execute the test script
again so now according to the script we
are not rese electing the radio button
because this is already selected by
default
and in this test script if you see now
all the green colored one if you see
okay the open command ran successfully
store command raw and successfully it
came to the if condition it checked if
the gender was F or M it found that this
condition is
not true so can you see here all these
other statements in the if are in black
color that means these were not executed
instead it came to the else part and
then it executed all the commands in the
else part so this is how you use a if
condition in your selenium ID so let's
close this now as I said there are other
looping statements what we have like
while n loop or do repeat and times in
so I have couple of examples written
here let's walk through that and see so
let's take the while loop first so what
happens in this while loop let's say in
this while loop what I'm basically doing
is I have created a counter and I'm
counting it from one to five and then
displaying the value of the counter and
I'm using a while loop further so here
it says first I am setting a counter
value to one and then I'm saying
while the counter value is less than
five this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes five so once it sees
that counter is five it is going to exit
the loop and just print the value of the
counter it's as simple as while loop so
just to pay attention to the syntax the
way it has been used here so this
execute script is what a simpler
statement what I have used this could be
anything it could be any of your web
elements your performing certain
operations say there is a calculator
which you are using say a calculator on
to test so if you want to okie in
certain numbers until say the sum of the
numbers is 30 or something an example
like that could be a valid use case for
your while loop so you could use that so
let's execute this and see how the
counter works so if I execute this
command so now take a look at the log
here this is running while tests so
first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop and it executed the while
loop until the counter was assigned the
value 4 and once the counter became 5
the while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value so this is
how a while loop is used now similarly
the same function of using a counter I
have tried to use a do loop here so
let's look at it now in the do look what
happens is the first the script is
executed because is the first command
after the do statement so whatever is
between the do and repeat if is executed
and
then the condition is checked here so
here what I'm doing is I'm just first
assigning a counter with value zero and
I'm incrementing the counter every time
by ten and then I have a condition that
once the counter becomes fifty please
exit the loop that's all I'm doing here
and under the statement what I have
written here is every time the counter
gets incremented I am printing the value
of the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the way it is executing it
all right now let's see the lock running
do loop test
okay the counter has been initialized to
zero and then it executes the script in
this script is doing what it is just
incrementing the counter by 10 the
counter becomes 10 and then 20 30 40 and
50 so as soon as it becomes 50 it's
going to exit the loop and print the
value of the card so one thing to notice
is there is no web element or website
testing which I am doing from the script
however one thing what the ID needs is
it needs a starting point so whenever
you create a new test gate it asks you
to at least give it a URL from where it
can start though it is not going to
launch that URL it is going to launch
your browser definitely before even it
executes a single line of test so that
is something a mandatory in the ID so we
saw do loop we saw the while loop this
also caused something called as time
slip so which is what I have said here
times n n so this is something you can
specify a number of iterations you would
like to perform a set of commas so now
in this example what am i doing
I'm simply incrementing a counter by 1
right and I'm saying just increment that
is this is the only command which I want
to execute but I want it to execute two
types that's all so there is no other
conditions here it is simply saying
there is a set of command or a single
command which I want to execute it twice
and the number of times which I want to
execute is what I mentioned here in the
target so first initially I am assigning
a counter with value hundred and then I
am saying increment this counter by one
two times and then print the value of
the counter so let's execute this and
then change the number of times if I say
run test here so can you see this the
number of times it got it-- rated and
now the value is 102 why because initial
value was hundred in the loop
is the time slow I am saying the
iterations is to two times
execute the command which increments the
counter by one so that is why your
counter value becomes 102 now say I
increase this to say 10 so that we get a
feel of how the loop executes here and
same thing I will execute it now see it
you can visually see the number of times
the loop is getting executed alright and
in the lock you can see the values also
here okay can you see you so this loop
executed 10 times and hence the counter
value because 110 so these are a simple
ways of using these loops in the ID so
you can implement this loops for any
kind of functionality you may want to
perform on your web elements or any
logic which you want to build for your
test cases selenium side runner selenium
side runner is a command line runner
tool which allows the user to run your
selenium IDE test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases Baddeley and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain installations which we need to
do and some of the installation prereqs
are one is you need a node.js server and
what is this node.js server node.js
server is a powerful JavaScript based
platform and this is the platform which
is intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of course to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install our node.js server for
this so now let's look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side runner and running
it ok so let's go to my notes so the
selenium HQ dot R has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner I will just show you where
it is and you can use this as a
reference for any of the tests which you
are creating and using the site owner to
run it so let me open a new window here
let's go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
Runner including the setups what is the
prereqs installing the browser drivers
and how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the site or not so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base URL so this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you're working with the site run
okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
nodes yes okay so if you go to this
website no J's dot o-r-g
we opened the same browser okay all
right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
Windows installer do you have a Mac OS
installer you have line mix installers
also so if you're working with the
Windows machine there are two options
for you either you can go ahead and
download the MSI installer or you can
just download the zip and unzip it into
any folder on your system ok and since
I'm using Mac machine what I have done
is I have downloaded this version PKG
version and have installed it on my
machine ok so once you download say if
you're working on the windows machine so
say if 64-bit is what you require and
you click here and download the zip
package i'll show you how the folder
structure looks like so this is where i
have downloaded the node GEOSS
installable now if you look at the
windows 1 so this is what happens when
you download the zip file and unzip it
this is the folder structure it creates
and this is what we would need so NPM is
something which we would be using to
install all the packages which are
required on this node GSL and i will
explain to you what this packages are ok
so once you do this installation you
need to go and check if your
installation is gone properly or not so
for that what you do is go to your
terminal window or in your case if you
are using a Windows machine just open a
command prompt right and then you have
to just give this command here you say
NPM - week which is basically saying
what is the version of the node GS which
we have installed it is 6.9 ok now what
does this NPN NPM is nothing but it's an
orgeous package manager and it gets
installed with your node and this is
used to install all your other packages
or what it is called as modules on your
system so now with this we know that our
NPM has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
site Rana now with the selenium side
runner is our library which is available
to us and we need to install this
library using the NPN so let me go back
to my terminal again so I will just show
you the command what it does what we use
for installing this package or the
library and since I've already installed
on my machine I will not be are doing
the installation here so what you need
to do is so if
if you are a Windows user you can
directly give the commander's NPN
install - JEE selenium site Rana okay so
this is the command which you need to
give however if you're a Mac user or a
UNIX user since you need to use a root
user here what you need to do is just
say sudo once you press enter here it
will go ahead and install this complete
library on your system now since I've
already installed I'm not going to do
that okay so I'll just exit from this
now once the installation is done how do
you check whether your installation has
gone correctly or not you have to just
simply give a command like selenium side
run off - worship okay and now this will
give you the version number if the
installation has been successful so
right now the version installed which is
the latest version is 3.11 okay so so
far we have done the installation of the
node.js server we have done the
installation of the selenium now why do
all also you do this installation you
need to know that where is the selenium
IDE side runner has been installed right
as as I said it's a library or what you
popularly called as module in your NPM
it's for you to check whether where it
has got installed you simply need to go
to the directory I'll say LS - user
local library so if you see here you
will see something called as node
modules so whatever packages you were to
install using NPM would get installed in
this directory the node modules
directory so let's go ahead and see
whether I have my selenium site runner
there are mods so I'll just use the same
LS / node modules okay do you see this
selling inside runner is what has got
installed and previously - that when we
installed the node.js server it also
installed this NPM right so that is also
available under the same folder so far
so good so we have our selenium IDE
installed now now what else is required
so we installed the node.js we installed
the selenium side runner now we need
this browser drivers now what are this
browser drivers now what you did using
your ID verse let me in ID was we said
right in the ID itself I said run the
current test and since I'm using Firefox
browser here any test case using the IDE
plug-in on your Firefox you execute is
going to execute on the Firefox
okay same way if you are using the
selenium IDE on Chrome which is an
extension on Chrome and you run the test
cases there it is going to use the
chrome browser to run the test case
however any test cases or any automation
scripts you are going to write you want
your scripts to run on all the process
because you want to do a cross-browser
testing right so for that purpose what
we do through command line is we install
this browser drivers so say if you want
to run your test cases on edge browser
so that means you first need to install
your edge browse driver on your systems
before you run your test case on edge
process if you want to root for Chrome
similarly you need to download the
Chrome web driver and install it for
Firefox the same and once you install
that then you should be able to run it
on any browser now where are these
chrome browsers available so if you go
to the selenium HQ dot orc let me show
you that
okay in the selenium HQ website if you
go to this download tab and if you go
down here you will see something called
as third-party drivers bindings and
plugins and here you have a list of all
the browsers and it's corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go
download for example say I want to run
all my tests on Chrome browser right so
what I do is I click here okay
in the download session go to the latest
chromedriver available click on that and
then depending on which OS you're
working on if you're working on math
just download this if you're working on
Windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is you keep that drivers like for
example can you see this driver file so
this is my driver fact this is my
executable driver file so what I did was
I just downloaded this file format and I
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once I have this
available what I need to do is I need to
install this driver using again the NPM
command okay and to install this driver
what you need to do is you need to be in
the same directory where your driver
file is present okay in the same
directory you just issue this command
you say npm install - g and your chrome
driver this is it
so once you install this driver you
should be able to work with your own
driver got it very simple so similarly
if you're working with different
browsers say if you also want to run
your test cases with edge or internet
explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location so from here
like you have edge browser your opera
browser you have a Mozilla Firefox
browser so any of the browser which you
want to work with you have to just
download your driver from here place it
in this location and install it using
imp in command ok so since I will not be
executing this command again because
I've already installed it so once your
drivers are installed what's the next
step we are ready to execute our test
cases ok so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line Runner which is
called a selenium side run are ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right
ok now let's go ahead and see how do we
execute the test cases so let's go back
to our previous example
in this video where we wrote some of the
test cases for testing our control flows
okay so these are all the test cases now
if you observe here I have not created
any test suite we just had a default
suite which was created when we created
the project and we just went ahead and
created all the tests here for the side
runner to run we need to have a test
suite there so if I just try to run the
tests but let's try to run this what is
the name of this project control flows
so I will show you what happens if there
is no test suite defined for this so let
me clear the screen
and which is our project here this one
okay so what I will do is let me simply
go ahead and execute this project so to
execute any test this is the command
which you use you simply call selenium
side runner and the project name and
also once you have installed the
selenium side runner you can also check
the version of it so let's execute this
selenium side runner and the project
name project name is this now so now if
I press ENTER now see what happens
okay it's saying running the default
suite it is here it looks for a test
suite to start its execution okay so it
picked up the default suite which is
here okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test fit correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what I will do is I will say
first rename this let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so I have renamed now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
I'll just simply say add test and select
all this tests so we have around 4 tests
here so I'll just select on that so I'll
save this project
I'll go to my folder ID tests and the
same fair name I'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens okay
so there are multiple test cases here so
let's see all these test cases will be
run one after the other sequential so we
have that calorie counter test case and
then we have the loop test cases alright
so it is done so now let's understand
the flow of this test case okay so this
is where we started running over test
suite so it finished first test case it
finished the second test case it
finished the third test case and then
the fourth test case so all the four
test cases it has completed and it says
all the fourth passed total four and it
also shows you the total time taken for
the complete test suite to run and for
every test case what is the amount of
time required to execute again so this
is all the information which is
available if at all there is a failure
in any of the test case that would get
reflected here it would say for passed
one faith and total for executed okay so
this is the kind of report what you will
get to see good so far okay let's go
back to our notes and see whether we
have done everything so the other way of
running is say you have multiple browser
drivers installed and you want to run
this on a particular browser so during
that time what you can do is you can use
this command you can say it's selenium
side runner - C - C is nothing but
setting the capabilities capabilities
for what for the browser and then you
give a browser name here so you can say
chrome or you can say Firefox whatever
the browser of your choice and then give
your project name so with this what
happens is if your browser is installed
now we have to install the browser using
this come at correct so if your browser
is installed it will execute this
particular test suite on the browser
which you have mentioned here and that
is how you use the selenium side runner
to run your test cases on multiple
process now simply what you can do is
you can create a shell script or a batch
script you can add this line into a bad
script for the multiple browsers and you
can execute this so that way all your
test cases would execute it on all the
process so that way you can achieve your
cross browser test so other thing if you
remember I all
so said that command line runner like if
you go back to our presentation it says
we can run it for paddle testing now
let's see how do we achieve this
parallel testing now to achieve this
parallel testing there are certain steps
which you need to do in the ID so let's
go back to our test fit so we have this
test fit so if you go here and go to the
settings can you see this run in
parallel so you need to check this
checkbox to run all this test cases in
parallel so right now what happened when
we executed it all the test cases ran
sequentially one after the other okay so
for every test case there was a Chrome
browser launch and the Chrome browser
was closed before the next test what she
launched now let's try to do this I am
going to check this check box where it
says run in parallel and I will say
submit I'll save this project again now
same thing I'll overwrite this project
save done replace now let's go to a
terminal window and run this test cases
again so for that what I will do I'll
call the same command again however now
please observe the number of Chrome
browser windows it's going to open ok
I'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite ok can you see
this 3 Chrome browser windows open at
the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see him now look
at the complete execution here so what
it has done is it opened called the
browsers in parallel ok and it ran all
the test cases paralleling you will see
a big difference and since these are
very small test case you might not be
able to see a big difference in the
execution time however if you have got a
bigger or bigger test cases which you
are running you will see a remarkable
difference in the time taken by the
suite to run the test cases still here
you can see ok it's almost 11 seconds it
took whereas in the previous example it
tooks 13 seconds as I said the
difference is very small because our
test cases are very very my new test
cases right if you have a bigger test
cases where it launches the browser
launches your application under test
then you are doing multiple operation
you'll be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run that as
sequentially and when you run it back so
this is how you work with the ID and
this is how you achieve the parallel
execution ok so that
completes our selenium site random now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium ideal the first limitation
is you cannot export your ID scripts to
webdriver scripts the support is yet to
be added right so earlier in this video
I showed you there are ways to export
the scripts to j-unit and python however
the previous ide did have this
capability of exporting your scripts to
webdriver scripts and that support is
yet to be added to the new ID data
driven testing like using Excel files or
reading data from the CSV files and
passing it to your scripts so this
capability is not yet available in the
ideal so you cannot do data driven
testing data based testing is also not
possible so you cannot actually connect
your data base read the test data from
your database or even you cannot perform
any kind of data base testing reporting
facility so it does not have a good
reporting we saw when we use the command
line Runner or through the ID when we
run the test there is a very minimal
reporting capabilities what we could see
so it does not really have capabilities
of reporting like your test ends here at
the report engine all right so to sum it
up what all we did we learn in this
video we learned how to use the selenium
I do to create automation scripts we
also looked at some of the key features
of this new ID like the reusability of
the tests using the control flow
statements how do we use the debugger
and most importantly using the command
line Runner which is called a side
runner to run your tests on any browser
and also to run test case parallel so
this brings us to the end of this video
so hope you had a good learning with
this video and thank you very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here